alors si l'accord sur la rémunération
des médecins hospitaliers conclu dans le
cadre du ségur de la santé est à marquer
d'une pierre blanche est ce pour autant
une véritable avancée pour le secteur
hospitalier la crise sanitaire inédite
elle va t elle permettre de faire
évoluer le statut des personnels en
première ligne on en parle tout de suite
avec florence bouscat vice-présidente du
collectif inter bloc et avec que thierry
amouroux rue porte parole du syndicat
national des professionnels infirmiers
lance bousquet thiery amoureux merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors parmi les principales mesures
une hausse de 183 euros nets pour les
personnels soignants 450 millions pour
les médecins hospitaliers
une enveloppe de 55 millions pour les
internes des hausses de salaires pour
les personnels paramédicaux ou encore
des eaux gauche c'est historique selon
les mots du premier ministre est ce que
vous rejoignez son enthousiasme florence
bousquet en fait c'est très mitigé j'ai
un peu l'impression d'être
insidieusement projeté dans la peau du
docteur faust et avec l'alléchant a pas
de 180 euros qu'on nous qu'on nous met
un petit peu à toutes les sauces mais ce
que je lis surtout sur les sur les
accords s'apparente plutôt à un pacte un
peu démoniaque parce que il ya beaucoup
de petit alinéa ou en fait on conditions
oui un pacte démoniaque pourquoi
précisément par exemple le temps de
repos entre deux prises de postes qui
étaient avant de 12h à pass à 11 heures
le temps de travail qui étaient 35
heures va être augmenté à 40 heures il
ya beaucoup de choses en fait qui qui
sont pas annoncés mais qui sont mis en
tout petit comme dans les assurances
vous savez les petits alinéa quand on
lit pas en fin de contrat ça fait la
même chose en fait
thierry amouroux c'est petit alinéa en
fin de contrat comme vient de le
souligner florence bousquet vous aussi
vous font peur oui puis surtout on nous
avions trois revendications ouvrir des
lits créer des postes et revaloriser les
salaires sur la réouverture de lignes à
rien ils ont même refusé d un moratoire
alors que ce qui se passe sur le terrain
c'est qu'ils continuent à fermer des
lits au mois de juillet nous avons moins
d'hélico mois de janvier ils n'ont pas
du tout tenu compte de l'expérience du
duc au vide
même en alsace ils ont fermé 14 lits de
réanimation à strasbourg ils ont fermé
la réanimation de sélestat enfin bon au
niveau des postes qu'ils espèrent ont
créé 7500 sachant qu'il ya déjà des
milliers de postes non pourvus parce que
vous comprenez bien que travailler sous
payés en sous-effectif dont des
conditions de travail parfois lamentable
il ya des milliers de postes qui restent
vacants à l'hôpital mais juste mais
enfin sur les salaires alors là il faut
bien comprendre que cette année il n'y a
pas un centime pour les pour les
professionnels de l'hôpital va y avoir
une loi qui sera votée en décembre
et puis ensuite des décrets d arrêter et
cetera qui fait que sur la paye de fin
février les personnes enfin une hausse
de 98 euros rétroactive de quelques mois
mais enfin c'est pas grand chose c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui s'il ya eu un
mouvement si fort des personnels
infirmiers c'est parce que nous sommes
sous payé 21 pour cent de moins que le
restant de des infirmiers et européens
est ce que ces hausses de salaires
finalement est ce que justement elle se
réajuste par rapport au reste des
infirmiers européen avec du tout là où
on était à -21 % l'an prochain avec ses
183 euros nous serons à -10%
donc on sera un peu moins sous payés non
sera quand même largement sous payés
donc ce n'est pas possible
alors ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que l'aide du coup les gens ils
votent avec leurs pieds
c'est à dire que il démissionne de
l'hôpital les plus jeunes par travailler
à l'étranger dans les pays frontaliers
pour ceux qui parlent l'anglais dans les
pays anglo-saxons et puis ben voilà il
ya vous avez des milliers de postes
aujourd'hui qui sont non pourvus à
l'hôpital flanche cathinone flanche
bousquet ces hausses de salaires qui ont
été signés cet après midi finalement
est-ce que ça va permettre un petit peu
plus d'attractivité dans le secteur
hospitalier selon ce n'est pas du tout
du tout parce qu'en fait c'est de la
poudre de perlimpinpin qu'on nous jette
à la figure déjà au niveau des postes il
faut savoir qu'ils nous proposent à peu
près quinze mille postes
sachant que ça fait à peu près dix
postes par établissement parce qu'il ya
mille trois cent soixante établissements
en france alors qu'il faudrait pour les
ehpad trois cent mille postes en plus
100 milles pour les hôpitaux dont
d'ailleurs on est loin du compte donc
travailler dans des conditions où le
personnel sera mis à rude épreuve
parce qu'en fait il ya très peu de
personnel ça c'est pas possible les gens
vont pas il n'y a pas d'acte réactivité
possible la qualité de vie au travail
tout simplement on reconnaît pas la
pénibilité de notre profession donc il
est évident que il y aura pas plus de
l'infirmier qui vont travailler à
l'hôpital
en tout cas des désaccords finalement
autour des hausses des salaires
néanmoins on a moins parlé de
restructuration de l'hôpital qui était
aussi montré du doigt thierry amouroux
effectivement c'est ce qui manque
aujourd'hui selon vous oui puis il faut
bien comprendre qu'il ya trop
d'administratifs il ya toute la
technostructure drs quelque chose à
supprimer parce que ça fait beaucoup
d'emplois et mythique et coûte très cher
vous avez 11 mille agents ministère de
la santé dans une ère s prenons par
exemple la grèce ile de france vous avez
1200 agents et bien si on supprime et là
il reste pour confier les missions au
conseil régional avec eux sur l'exemple
des länder allemands un ministre de la
santé régional eh bien on voit que les
gens seraient proches du terrain est
capable de mieux connaître le territoire
de mieux réagir alors que les ars ont
été en dessous de tout pendant la phase
peu vide et 1200 places d'arrêt
supprimer ça permet de créer 3600 postes
d'infirmières et d'aides-soignantes à
l'hôpital donc c'est vite vous savez
quand on compare l'allemagne et la
france
nous avons en france 30% d'infirmières
en moins et 35% d'administratifs en plus
donc si on veut faire des économies on
peut en faire quoi
les derniers statistiques de l'insee
vous allez plus de 102 mille agents
administratifs à l'hôpital alors que
vous avez que 71 1000 médecins et 30000
interne plus d'administratif que deux
médecins
il ya quand même un souci fluence
bousquet à quel type de restructuration
vous vous attendez finalement en fait on
est un peu déçu ça a été menée de façon
frénétique depuis sept semaines et on
n'a pas du tout consulter les les
professionnels de terrain puisque les
infirmiers qui représente quand même
sept cent mille en france ont été
complètement évincé
donc tout le reste ça va tout le reste
va en fait suivre c'est à dire que ce
qui concerne la formation
ça fait déjà depuis 2008 personnellement
qu au bloc opératoire les ibode demande
la réingénierie de leur diplôme
on leur accorde pas par contre bon je me
félicite quand même pour nos
collaborateurs qui sont diététiciens
préparateur en pharmacie et laborantins
qui yeux on va avoir la réingénierie de
leur diplôme mais voilà nous on est
toujours dans la tente de type 2008
et c'est une spécialisation quand même
qui a besoin de de progresser on en
demande de plus en plus de technicité de
qualification de compétences et voilà
donc les postes qui vont suivre les
futurs piliers sur la formation seront
menées de la même façon qu'on était
menés les rémunérations c'est à dire on
craint le pire à l'orf lance bousquet
thierry amouroux vous restez avec nous
parce qu'en ce moment même une grande
fête pour les soignants a lieu au grand
palais c'est à paris 800 personnels
hospitaliers ont été conviés par le
ministère de la santé
une soirée de remerciement est dommage
l'umq à laquelle participent olivier
ferrand ministre de la santé
pour plus de précisions on va tout de
suite retrouvé devant le grand palais
notre reporter thomas bonnin
un thomas bon soir alors qu'elle est
dans quelle atmosphère se déroule cette
soirée mais écoutez les invités
continuent à arriver ici au grand palais
les retardataires puisque la soirée
démarre officiellement à 20 heures
soirée vous l'avait dit pour remercier
le personnel soignant le personnel
soignant qui étaient en première ligne
pendant la crise du comique 19 ils sont
800 soignants avoir été conviés pour
cette soirée il vous propose d'écouter
l'un d'entre eux il s'appelle jean
baptiste il est originaire de la région
nouvelle aquitaine et les venues prêter
main forte aux hôpitaux en région
parisienne il nous explique dans quel
état d'esprit ils abordent cette soirée
donc en compagnie du ministre des
solidarités de la santé je propose l
écoute je pense que c'est l'heure du
symbolique aujourd'hui c'est la
symbolique après effectivement il ya eu
aujourd'hui des avancées au niveau du
studio la santé après je pense que
l'image du grand palais de nous recevoir
aujourd'hui c'est plus symbolique pour
le gouvernement aujourd'hui
effectivement qu'on m'a appelé il ya un
mois je me questionnais sur l'intérêt de
venir ou pas voilà je suis pas
personnellement moi je ne fais pas plus
plusieurs que ça après je suis je suis
content surtout de représenter les gens
et qui j'ai travaillé en banlieue
parisienne sont des gens avec
professionnalisme et qui était qui s'est
dévoué vraiment pour la passion et je
suis content et amoureux clos
vous l'avez entendu cette soirée
intervient dans un contexte particulier
puisque aujourd'hui les accords du ségur
de la santé ont été signés et le
personnel soignant sera également de la
partie demain pour la cérémonie du 14
juillet dans la capitale mais dans cette
soirée il n'y a pas que des soignants il
ya aussi des personnes issues de la
société civile ou encore des membres de
la cellule de crise du ministère mais
aussi des proches de soignants qui ont
perdu la vie pendant cette pandémie de
kovy 19 là encore je propose d'écouter
le témoignage d'une famille qui a perdu
à un proche pendant cette crise dont
quito micro-signes à l'auberge
c'est un bel événement après j'aurais
aimé pouvoir vivre ça mais
dans d'autres conditions ce que c'est
suite quand même un événement tragique
donc c'est un peu particulier
on a été invité par la rs a tant donné
que c'était on va travailler à l'hôpital
en tant que personnel soignant on a été
convié par la rs c'est quelque chose de
bien après ça n'efface pas ce qui s'est
passé le nombre de moyens qui a pu y
avoir en tout cas dans les hôpitaux
voilà donc pour cette soirée qui se
déroule au grand palais le grand palais
qui accueille gracieusement cette soirée
dans une forme de mécénat avec le
gouvernement via noter que évidemment
malgré les tenues de soirée les
participants sont amenés à porter un
masque puisque selon le ministre de la
santé les gestes barrières devant
impérativement être respectée ce soir
merci beaucoup thomas pour eux toutes
ces précisions thomas bonnin en direct
devant le grand palais à paris et ont
continué de parler de ces accords du
ségur de la santé avec bouffe laurent
bousquet vice présidente du collectif
inter belote est avec vous tirez
amoureux porte parole du syndicat
national des professionnels infirmiers
peut-être un mot sur cette soirée ce
soir
tout d'abord est ce que vous avez été
invité et qu'elle elle regarde ont porté
sur cette initiative du ministère de la
santé
alors personnellement nous n'avons pas
été invité en tant que collectif inter
bloc et le regard que j'ai de cette
soirée c'est encore mitigé parce que
normalement le coville devait être
reconnu comme maladie professionnelle
pour tous les soignants et petit à petit
on apprend qu en fait seuls les
soignants qui ont été gravement touchés
et qu'ils auront de graves séquelles par
la suite seront reconnues comme maladies
professionnelles donc c'est toujours des
annonces et derrière ils se cachent des
choses qui sont faites dramatique pour
les soignants c'est comme pour les prime
de 1500 euros qui auront finalement été
donné avec parcimonie voir que 2 500
euros à certains n'y a pas d'autre et
c'est toujours des effets de style qui
sont dramatiques pour les soignants qui
ont été cueillis qui ont répondu
vraiment présent chaque fois qu'ils ont
été sollicités et autour de moi
j'entends j'entends des soignants qui
disent la prochaine vague ça sera sans
moi et je pense que le gouvernement doit
entendre aussi
cet appel parce que je suis pas certaine
que tout le monde répondra présent si à
votre avis sur sur cette soirée ce soir
au grand palais c'est une action de
communication qui cache l'élément qui
aujourd'hui parce que moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que au bout de deux
mois de déconfinement on est toujours en
manque de moyens à l'hôpital c'est à
dire que on est en tension sur les gants
sur les / blues / les médicaments
d'anesthésié et dont demain si on est
confronté à une deuxième vague mais
comment va-t-on faire
on a l'impression qu'ils n'ont pas
encore tiré les leçons des manque cruel
de la première vaincre qui ont abouti à
des morts qui auraient pu être évitable
si on avait le matériel nécessaire et on
se retrouve confronté à la même
situation nous mêmes en tant que
soignant on n'a toujours pas de masques
ffp2 en quantité suffisante
donc voilà on est quand même très
inquiet le fait qu'ils continuent à
fermer des lits ça veut dire que on aura
encore moins 10 pour répondre aux
besoins en cas de cette deuxième vague
et puis surtout on voit bien que du coup
on n'a pas les capacités pour prendre en
soins tous les patients non qu'ovide qui
ont été déprogrammés en mars avril mai
et parsème donc des patients qui ont des
pathologies chroniques des interventions
chirurgicales programmées mais non
urgentes qui ont été repoussés mais qui
vont être repoussées de nombreux mois
parce que alors que l'on devrait prendre
plus de monde en fait ils réduisent les
moyens donc on n'arrive pas à absorber
le retard sur le planning des mois
qu'ovide flandres ou stern
c'est inquiétant florence bousquet est
ce que vous confirmez ce que vous venez
d'entendre ce que viennent nous dire
thierry amouroux à savoir eh bien il ya
encore une pénurie de matériel
aujourd'hui dans les hôpitaux alors tout
à fait et pas seulement dans les
hôpitaux puisque c'est aussi valable
pour les crimes les cliniques privées
puisque moi je fais partie des du privé
où on manque effectivement de masse de
callot de de blues stérilisables c'est à
dire que pour travailler au bloc
opératoire nous faut des détenus stérile
et on vend que le manque déjà avant même
qu'ils aient la vague qui va arriver au
manque de matériels donc c'est
dramatique dramatiques sur ça c'est
quelque chose que vous remontez aux
autorités régulièrement
bien sûr les ars sont tout à fait au
courant puisqu'il délivre au compte
gouttes les curares et les les
hypnotiques donc même pour les
interventions on est obligé de jongler
en disant qu'on va t'elle patients
celui-là on va lui faire juste une loco
régionale
il n'aura pas d'âge et on est obligé
voilà de de fer avec le matériel etc
c'est une fois de plus dramatique tirée
amour n'est quand même la puissance
mondiale et on se dit comment est ce
possible
thierry amouroux vous confirmer que s'il
ya une deuxième vague ça sera encore la
catastrophe c'est ce que vous nous dites
ce soir on va avoir un nouveau problème
de manque de moyens de protection et
donc du coup ben les personnes
deviennent contaminantes à leur tour et
y est vous avez entendu ce qu'a dit
florence on est obligé de baisser les
doses ou de trouver des substituts pas
pour les produits d'un et saisit donc on
était déjà confronté à ça pendant la
première vague
c'est un vrai souci de santé publique
les moyens ne sont pas ni suffisamment
sûre sur l'hôpital il faut absolument
qu'on réorganise sa queue on produise
les médicaments en france qu'on produise
le matériel en france de façon à être
indépendant parce que là on est
complètement dépendant du marché mondial
comme tout le monde veut
du matériel en ce moment il n'y a pas
assez de matières produire de matières
premières et de produits finis et c'est
un vrai souci
visiblement bas on n'est pas à
l'appareil industriel français en
capacité de répondre aux besoins de
santé de la population au revient dans
la logique faut fabriquer des voitures
sous forme etc et des avions
bannon personnes les achète d une
réduction de l'aviation enfin voilà on a
l'impression qu'ils vivent pas dans le
monde réel
en tout cas bon il ya eu cette hausse de
salaire aujourd'hui on en a parlé pour
tous les soignants
demain il ya cet hommage durant le 14
juillet un hommage aux soignants hommage
national cette soirée ce soir on a parlé
également au grand palais pour les
soignants malgré tout cela vous estimez
que le gouvernement ne vous entend pas
ne vous écoute pas d'irradiation qui
nous écoutent pas il n'a pas du tout
entendu nos revendications donc on ne
peut pas laisser faire des choses comme
ça et du reste demain il ya un appel
national qui est lancée par par tous les
tous les mouvements infirmiers pour
démontrer une fois de plus notre
mécontentement
justement pour conclure là après l'autre
thiery amoureux vous serez demain dans
la rue pour défiler pour l'hôpital bien
sûr il ya des dizaines de deux
mouvements dans toute la france et il y
en a un qui part de république à 14h
pour aller à bastille
voilà c'est pour continuer à maintenir
la pression
on demande également à la population de
saisir les maires qui sont ceux qui
président les l'instance de l'hôpital de
saisir les parlementaires qui vont voter
le budget des des hôpitaux
on ne peut pas continuer comme ça il
faut vraiment mettre des moyens sur
l'hôpital parce que derrière il ya des
morts vous comprenez que en france on a
cinq fois moins de lits de réanimation
que l'allemagne et on a eu quatre fois
plus de morts là on n'est pas simplement
des salariés qui dit fonds dont leur
outil de travail
on est des soignants qui est alertant
sur la populace de la population
sur les dents chez la population est en
danger parce qu'il n'ya pas assez moyen
on a fermé quantité de lit on a fermé
des petits hôpitaux des petites
maternités des petits services d'urgence
et aujourd'hui la france n'a que 5 19
lits pour 1000 habitants
là où l'allemagne en a huit planches
bousquet en un mot pour conclure moi je
conclurai juste sur l'aspect financier
c'est à dire que l'état fait un peu
marchands de tapis avec nos
rémunérations à payer en deux fois et
seulement une partie de nos plus qu'on
avait demandé mais là ce qui s'annonce
c'est que financièrement il va falloir
mettre beaucoup plus d'argent pour
acheter tout ce matériel qui manquent et
les prix sont en train de flamber parce
qu'il n'y a pas de matière première
comme disait thierry donc il va bien
falloir qu'il trouve de l'argent et une
fois de plus ça ça n'aura pas été
anticipée et voilà c'est donc c'est une
vraie catastrophe
si à tous les deux en tout cas d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et wright sur
air france lance bousquet je rappelle
que vous êtes vice présidente du
collectif inter bloc thierry amouroux
porte parole du syndicat national des
professionnels infirmiers merci à tous
les deux